- A coelacanth is a very primitive fish.
Some people refer to it
as a "living fossil."
There are two species
that exist in the wild.
Sometimes they're caught
by long-line fishermen.
It had been known from fossils at least
a hundred years before they
found a living specimen.
My name is Kevin Swagel,
I am an Assistant Collections Manager
in the Fish Division at the Field Museum.
And today we're going to
be unboxing the coelacanth.
We have got three coelacanths
in our collection.
We obtained them in the
'60s, '70s, and '80s
from the Shedd Aquarium.
When we received 'em, they
were put in formaldehyde.
And formaldehyde is a fixative,
it actually toughens the
tissues, hardens the tissues.
Then once the formaldehyde does its thing
and the specimen is real tough,
we wash out the formaldehyde
with water baths
and transfer it to 70% ethanol.
That's what we keep our fish in.
Coelacanths are a very oily fish.
Their flesh is nasty,
it's filled with urea,
and oil and wax and esters,
so people do not eat them.
If we look at the top of the
tank where they're stored,
there's actually an oily
film on top of the alcohol.
That oil is coelacanth oil
and it actually smells,
and when I go home after
handling coelacanths
I usually get a train seat, because people
don't want to sit near me.
So, yeah, they do smell a little bit,
but you get used to it.
Sometimes fish populations
may be reduced over time
through pollution or
draining of rivers or lakes,
but our collection here
is like a time capsule.
We know what fish were living
in those rivers or lakes
before they were polluted or drained.
The detail in the specimens is amazing.
Under a microscope you
can see all the little
fin connections and vertebrae
connections and scale counts.
Everything is preserved so beautifully.
A specimen can be 200 years old and
you have this beautiful preservation.
You can still do all the measurements
and photographs and everything
of that specimen for research.
It's kind of like The
Shape of Water moment.
(group laughs)
I watched it last night,
by the way, I rented it.
So, it's cool.
- [Voice Offscreen] I haven't seen it yet.